friendship should be one of the high
points of existence
and yet it's also the most routinely
disappointing thing we have to deal with
too often you're at supper at someone's
house there's an impressive spread and
the hosts have evidently gone to a lot
of trouble
but the conversation is meandering and
devoid of any real interest
it flits from an overlong description of
the failings of the in-flight service
on a particular airline to a strangely
heated discussion about the tax code
the intentions of the hosts are hugely
touching but
as so often we go home wondering what on
earth the whole performance was really
about
the key to the problem of friendship is
to be found in an
odd sounding place a lack of a sense of
purpose
our attempts at friendship tend to go
adrift because we collectively resist
the task
of developing a clear picture of what
friendship might really be
for the problem is that we're unfairly
uncomfortable with the idea of
friendship
having any declared purpose because we
associate purpose
with the least attractive and most
cynical of motives
yet purpose doesn't have to ruin
friendship and in fact
the more we define what a friendship
might be for the more we can focus in
on what we should be doing with every
person in our lives
or indeed the more we can helpfully
conclude that we shouldn't be with them
at all
there are at least four things we might
be trying to do with the people we know
firstly networking it's an unfairly
maligned idea
with small fragile creatures in a vast
world
our individual capacities are entirely
insufficient
to realize the demands of our
imaginations so of course we need
collaborators
accomplices who can align their
abilities and energies with ours
this idea of friendship was given a lot
of space in classical literature
take the argonauts the legendary ancient
greek tale
which traced how a heroic captain called
jason networked in order to assemble a
band of friends
to sail on the argo in search of the
golden fleece
later the same idea emerged when jesus
networked to put together a band of 12
disciples
with whom he could spread one or two
world-changing ideas about forgiveness
and compassion
rather than diminish our own efforts as
we hand out our business cards
such prestigious examples can show how
elevated and ambitious
networking friendships could ideally be
secondly reassurance the human condition
is full of terror
we're always on the verge of disgrace
danger and disappointment
and yet such are the rules of polite
conduct that we're permanently in danger
of imagining
that we are the only ones to be as crazy
as we know we are
we badly need friends because with the
people we know only superficially
there are few confessions of sexual
compulsion
or of regret rage and confusion these
superficial acquaintances refuse to
admit
that they too are going slightly out of
their minds
yet the reassuring true friend gives us
access to a very necessary and accurate
sense
of their own humiliations and follies
insights
with which we can begin to judge
ourselves and our sad and compulsive
lives
slightly more compassionately thirdly
fun despite talk of hedonism and
immediate gratification
life gives us constant lessons in the
need to be serious
we have to guard our dignity avoid
looking like a fool
and pass as a mature adult the pressure
can become
onerous and in the end even dangerous
that's why we constantly need access to
people we can trust enough
to be silly with them they might most of
the time be training to be a
neurosurgeon
or advising middle-sized companies about
their tax liabilities
but when we're together we can be
therapeutically daft
we can put on actions shared lewd
fantasies or doodle on the newspaper
adding a huge nose and a missing front
tooth to the president
or giving the fashion model distended
ears and masses of curly hair
the fun friend solves the problem of
shame around important but
unprestigious sides of ourselves
fourthly
clarifying our minds to a surprising
degree
it's very hard to think on our own the
mind is
skittish and squeamish as a result many
issues lie confused within us
we feel angry but are not sure why
something is wrong
with our job but we can't pin it down
the thinking friend
holds us to the task they ask gentle but
probing questions
which act as a mirror that assists us
with the task
of knowing ourselves side effect of
getting a bit more precise about what
we're trying to do with our social lives
is that we're likely to conclude that in
many cases we're spending time with
people
for no truly identifiable good reason
these proto-friends share none of our
professional ambitions or interests
they aren't reassuring and may indeed be
secretly really very excited by the
possibility of our failure
we can't be cathartically silly around
them and they aren't in the least bit
interested in furthering
our or their path to self-knowledge they
are
like so many of the people in our social
lives simply in our orbit
as a result of some unhappy accident
that we've been too sentimental
to correct we should dare to be a little
ruthless in this
area culling acquaintances isn't a sign
that we've lost belief in friendship
it's evidence that we're starting to get
clearer and therefore more demanding
about what a friendship could really be
in the best way
the price of knowing what friendship is
for may be
a few more evenings at home in our own
company
you